hello i'm jistransky welcome to my talk
about efficient software development why
talk about this i work on os migrate
project which is an openstack cloud to
cloud migration toolkit
and we have a very small team of three
people for everything around the project
from development to testing to
documentation writing to ci operations
and we do have quite a complex ci
and to supporting users who run into any
issues
so in general there's quite a
lot on our plate you can probably relate
to that
so how do we
deal with that do we work insane hours
no that's not good for health so we need
to
improve how we spend the time at work
one way to do that is to try to increase
the intentionality and decrease the
aimlessness of what we're doing so
uh asking questions like what am i
solving by doing this is it worth the
time or how much time is it worth for
existing activities that means
retrospecting not getting stuck in
obsolete activities
and uh often it's the
um that is the activities or patterns
that everyone in the team sort of
dislikes
that needs some sort of looking at
for new goals that we're that we want to
set for ourselves
it's not enough to ask
what do we want to achieve
we need to at the same time ask
how much of our time is this call worth
if we solve it
how much benefits is going to bring so
how much time should we spend on it and
then we may find that we need to adjust
the scope of the goal or maybe drop the
goal completely
experiments
do experiments mean going aimlessly no
they don't have they don't have to mean
going aimlessly experiments are often
necessary for progress
but we have to still define
why uh for the experiment the scope
where we want to go and where we don't
want to go and time box the experiment
we shouldn't get just card blanche to do
whatever we want for however long we
want
the other way
that helps quite a lot is to increase
order and consistency and decrease
chaos
in whatever you're doing
there's some sort of inherent complexity
to the tasks that you're doing you can
you cannot remove that but there is
often also some edit complexity which
comes from
doing things up sub-optimally so
um this is inc from inconsistencies
doing chores manually that should have
been automated and just generally not
being organized enough
there's a concept called decision
fatigue
uh basically it means you have some sort
of brain power for the day and if you
deplete that the quality of your
decisions goes down and you start
avoiding decision making
so
we should keep our brain power for the
important things so everything that can
be automated should be automated
and if we cannot automate something then
we should at least document it so that
we don't have to hold it in our memory
the other point here is about
consistency and it's that consistency
with existing sub-optimal patterns can
be better than doing an isolated
improvement so if we're making a code
patch
first and foremost we keep it consistent
with the rest of the project and then if
we want to improve something we make
sure to improve it everywhere and not in
an isolated place so that we don't bring
chaos into the project and we keep
consistency
some examples of
sort of this period of efficiency that
we do in os migrate
that's our ci philosophy and ci is the
focal point of qa for us we've automated
all testing that we can that we possibly
can
and there's a strip separation between
the tests and ci the interface is
documented very well and and what uh
what that gives us is that all test
types are runnable by developers exactly
as in ci if we if a developer want
wanted they could set up their own ci
based on the documentation of their
interfaces
we also have a containerized developer
nci environment so we containerize the
common dependencies so that we're yeah
we have more commonality and consistency
easily achievable in the project
our testing philosophy is we strictly
separate internal logic in the code from
external api calls and that allows us to
write unit tests
without mocks
mocks
tend to be a maintenance nightmare
because they get out of sync with the
real world and then they bring more
problems than they're worth
so
with that we write unit tests for pure
internal logic only and whenever we want
to test something involving external
calls we write functional tests for that
and this combination gives us tests that
are easy to write and maintain
for ci operations we have the complex ci
of three openstack clouds including five
routers 11 subnets and 20 servers but
that's all virtual
so we don't have to deal with hardware
procurement and higher obsolescence and
it scales dynamically if you wanted to
have four clouds we can have them
tomorrow it's all software defined and
automated so if something goes wrong we
can rerun the automation and the ci can
get redeployed
in summary the general points
keep costs and
effort proportional to benefits define
your why's your scope time box do
retrospectives
and keep your brain power for the
important stuff automate everything that
you can document the rest and keep
consistency in your project
thanks for listening and have a good day